good morning believe nation today's
message is make a difference over to you
sergey brin the challenge of a problem
are the importance isn't that related to
how likely you are to achieve it and and
in fact even when you go after a more
ambitious goal even if you fail to
achieve that one all the side effects
that come along the way can be that much
more rewarding and significant in their
own right and so you know I feel lucky
that I fell into doing something that I
feel really matters you know getting
people information around the world
about anything I I wish there was a way
to convey that to you know to the world
at large obviously all of you already
have this religion but it's very
rewarding when you work on something you
think is going to make a big difference
and yeah it's a little bit harder but I
think I think the passion that one might
bring with it brings so much more energy
to that that you're more likely to
succeed if you are not trying to make a
difference as an entrepreneur in my view
you're sunk you're not gonna last a long
time it's not gonna happen for you
you're not gonna make a lot of money and
unfortunately that happens to a lot of
entrepreneurs because a lot of us have
noble intentions getting in but then the
challenge becomes hey Evan I gotta I
gotta pay the bills right I get it food
on the table how do I support myself or
my family and make this work the thing
that gets you through the crap of
starting to business the hard times the
struggle what gets you through is
feeling like you're meaningful you're
important and I don't know that there's
much that there's much more important
things in your life than feeling like
what you're doing is having an impact on
others I can't express how positive and
good that makes me feel there's a reason
why I start off my day every day looking
at my YouTube comments is because you
guys make me feel good it's because I
feel like the work that I'm doing is me
and is important and even if I wasn't
getting paid to do it I would still do
it because it fills my soul right you
want to do things that fill your soul
that add value to people's lives and
then you can get paid to do but there's
always a gap when you start there's a
gap in the value that you can provide
and the money that you're making and and
the struggle becomes how do you keep
going through that gap right how do you
keep pushing through even though you're
not making money and having a minimal
impact because you know that if you keep
going it's eventually gonna work out how
do you have that confidence and faith
and belief that if you just keep going
it's going to work out and for me it
comes from knowing that even if I've
touched one person it's meaningful it's
helpful it's important it's making a
difference and when in the early days of
my youtube channel just as an examples
it's all you guys are watching my
youtube channel I felt like I wanted to
stop on some days I felt like man I'm
putting so much time and effort and work
into making these videos and nobody is
commenting on it nobody's liking it I'm
not getting subscribers I'm not getting
the growth that I want and it sucks and
it's frustrating it makes you feel like
man I want to do something more
meaningful and valuable with my life
where I'm making a contribution and then
I would get a comment I get one person
saying Evan thank you so much of that
video ever not that video you made
really helped me and that was just
enough juice just enough gas to help me
keep my car going a little bit further
until I got the next comment and now
it's easy because I built the momentum
because there's comments in the video
because you guys are so amazing I built
that up but the struggle is at the
beginning of anything that you're doing
you're gonna suck you're not gonna get
the momentum that you want fast enough
it's never fast enough the thing that
helps you get going and the things that
help you get through the things that
help you wake up every day and keep
putting energy into your business is
knowing that the work that you're doing
is making a difference and the minute
that you feel like you're not making a
difference anymore that's when you're
gonna stop that's when you're gonna quit
and probably when you should quit or at
least transition your business of doing
something more where you are having an
impact and add impact where you are
having an impact making a difference on
somebody's life so the question is a
today is how are you making a difference
in the world we're going a little deeper
today really
to find out leaving the comments below I
want to know the difference that you are
making doesn't have to be big but the
difference that you are making or you
want to have the difference you want to
make leave in the comments I'll join in
the discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events Press